we appear at your science has been doing
some a talking with us about Graz
thanks so much for having me it's
exciting to be here and I've really
enjoyed the talks this week I think my
talk will interact a bit with salons a
bit with Julius from earlier today and
of course with Kobe's work which is
directly relevant to some of the things
I'm going to talk about so we're in a
very different world and privacy than
just 10 years ago we were in kind of a
wild-west 20 years ago and slowly the
legislation and regulations have begun
to catch up and of course the
enforceability of the GD P R was a
complete change
I think the GD P R is as consequentials
intellectual property law that's not
quite understood yet but it is it's a
big deal and then here in California we
have a law called the consumer the
California consumer Privacy Act I helped
write the initiative not the CCP act
yeah the initiative that became to this
the CCPA
was part of my work but it essentially
would happen is the the the initiative
which would have been voted on by
Californians was withdrawn in order to
have a legislative compromise and I can
talk I can talk about why that happened
in some detail but what I want to talk
about today is the different ways in
which the GD P R and C CPA sets up
strategic basically strategic approaches
for advancing privacy and how this
community might be able to make sense of
those balancing regimes and my goal is
is to have a fair balancing of these
provisions my experience is a long time
doing privacy litigation and what
happens in these cases is the defense
attorneys show up with usually second or
third-tier institution economists
who make really like arguments that that
can be kind of crazy but they're also
one-eyed in the sense that they only
look at the cost to businesses they
never look at risk to consumers or to
the group interests in privacy so I
think this this group is is uniquely
well-suited for thinking through in
trying to quantify some of those some of
those interests so I'm going to talk
about examples in the in the California
law and and then in the GDP are just
some background information regulation
is special it's it's very different and
I have a feeling that you all know this
but it's different than standard
consumer protection because whether
you're regulating cars or bicycles
fundamentally cars and bicycles have to
have a certain number of wheels and a
motor and so on whereas information
products are abstract and changeable and
what I see is a practitioner is that it
is entirely possible to escape privacy
law by creating special corporate
entities and de-identification
to to escape regulation I can give some
very specific examples of that so the
result of this is that privacy law and
especially privacy advocates can sound a
little unhinged and the reason why is
that for years they've been looking at
the industry and they've been seeing
industry actors use technical trickery
and special corporate forms to run
around privacy rules there's a couple
other issues here one is that the
regulators and the privacy field are
really solipsistic and they tend to
think of them their own experience they
don't they don't think about privacy
issues in a scientific way and it needs
sense they look at their own facebook
and say well I don't see ads or I see
ads that I like or I've never had a
problem with this that or the other so
our own experiences with these services
misleads us and causes us to think only
from our frame and our frame of course
our is the frame of elites
of people who actually can read you know
most people can't read can't couldn't
certainly couldn't make sense of a Terms
of Service and so on so we are highly
solipsistic and how we conceive of and
understand the problems of information
privacy and then on the other side you
know the the privacy advocates can agree
about these things but they also know
that if you kind of if you look at the
industry they kind of get their way by
hiding so hiding the privacy impacts of
things a great example yesterday
sundar Pichai wrote an op-ed in The New
York Times that said well you know if
you care about privacy you can buy an
ad-free version of YouTube of course
there's the privacy issues are still
there all the tracking is still there
you just don't see ads that is a very
typical argument from the information
industry there they are
they're extremely almost Machiavellian
and if you look back at the hade that
you know the history of like Larry Page
Larry Page opposed Google zeitgeist why
well the zeitgeist tells you if you see
the zeitgeist report you know that
Google tracks you that you cannot escape
that conclusion so he didn't want like
these billboards that showed what was
happening in Google search and so on and
then Eric Schmidt formalized this he
called it the hiding strategy so this is
how Google has dealt with privacy so
this has made privacy advocates more
stringent and also calling for laws that
are also like that reach almost a level
of Magisterial detail and it becomes
very frustrating when you sit down and
actually read the GDP are the GDP are
and privacy laws appear so crazy because
they are regulating crazy systems so
there's other things here I think most
of this stuff you're familiar with the
other kind of interesting one that is
worth making explicit is
u.s. privacy law and and European law
differs in a great degree in that the US
law tends to be clearer and create
commands whereas the European law is
very principled based and there's
reasons for that and this also created
creates a big divide American lawyers
are often completely perplexed by texts
like the gdpr
they can't make any sense of it because
it speaks at a principals level and
American law typically does not do this
so let me give some examples of
provisions in these laws that I think
are going to be really important and I
think this community could shed light up
on one of them is a language that makes
note doesn't make a lot of sense of to
read it but as with a lot of legislative
language it's a it's a product of
compromise and that's why it's so
confusing so the people who wrote the
California consumer Privacy Act they
wanted to prohibit companies from kind
of coercing people into giving away
their privacy okay so you know alright
so you don't let people just like can
send everything away well what if I
offer you a financial inducement right
what if you know you can imagine a world
where Google Google and Facebook have so
much money they could pay you so the
architects said no no we can't have that
we have to somehow bend that but other
people said no wait a minute if you know
we live in a free market economy you
should be able to sell your privacy for
services if you don't want to pay for
facebook you should be able to just pay
with data so the legislation reflects a
an intractable disagreement between
these two sides and they came out with
this language that says essentially it
allows businesses to give financial
inducements for waiving privacy
essentially for allowing companies to
collect and use and sell personal data
to third third parties but it places
these interesting rules on it
so businesses may offer differential
service if that price or difference is
directly related to the value provided
to the business by the consumers data
does that mean I think this is an area
for study that could be super
interesting right what what exactly is
the value to the business from the data
and then there's a kind of up there
there's a there's there's a limit on
this so you know these two groups
couldn't agree on what the normative
outcome should be so they came up with
this weird compromise so you're allowed
to do this they're allowed to make these
offers but you have to give explicit
notice of them and then to a business
shall not use financial incentives that
are unjust unreasonable coercive or
usurious in nature so this was to deal
with the problem of what if facebook
says okay we'll let you pay and then you
can have like a privacy friendly
Facebook or a privacy friendly Google
but the price is $1,000 a month this is
the kind of rationale they didn't want
they didn't want services overcharging
so somewhere there's this sweet middle
place where people get people get things
in exchange for their data and it's
unclear what that compromise should be
or will be so they're I think there's
very interesting analysis this community
could do about privacy is an individual
right and a group right and what it
would mean to give inducements to allow
sale of personal information I think the
other thing that's gonna be really
interesting about this is that because
notice is required companies are going
to have to affirmatively
declare how much your data are worth
it's going to be super interesting and
and I don't know what those calculations
could look like and look on one level it
could be how much your data
is worth it's sold which guess what is
not very much but literally pennies you
know basically facts about you on the
market for data you know your home
address and the fact that your male or
female on your age and your income all
divided you know all put together is
worth something like four or five cents
okay so that's not so great but what if
the benefit is something else what if
the benefit to the business is something
like a psychological like lock-in so
having your data could be valuable for
other reasons network effects from
knowing who you're connected to and so
on so this is gonna be a very
interesting aspect of the California
consumer Privacy Act and I'm not sure
how businesses are gonna comply with it
January January 2020 and they're gonna
have to comply because it is highly
unlikely that a federal law will pass
before January 2020 and I'm a
practitioner all of our clients are
coming into compliance because you
cannot you can't wait so let's say that
bill let's say the federal bill passes
on November 1st it's already too late
you can't comply in one month so small
and big firms alike are saying get into
compliance with the California law now I
think we're likely to see a draft the
federal legislation around September but
it's unlikely to pass because you need
you need a lot of stars to align a lot
of reasons to think it will not pass
yeah I'm sorry for not making this
explicit so the the I did the starting
point for a federal legislation would
preempt this so essentially take away
the ability of the states to regulate in
this field and the other very important
aspect of business is to eliminate the
private right of action so this law has
a private right of action that allows
plaintiffs to sue although it's quite
awkward and it doesn't work very well
you could still sue and impose
picking costs even if you lost the case
yeah funny about this does this allow or
prohibit a business from offering
different prices or levels of service
that are different for you and for me
like if your data is more valuable and
I'm allowed to charge you yes indeed
it's super interesting right you have to
differentiate based on the value of the
consumers data it doesn't require I I
don't know if it has to be how granular
that has to be I mean I think most
companies are thinking about this is
there's one price for everyone but you
could imagine a world where my data is
less expensive than yours so this is
what there are many amendments to the
CCPA some of which have already moved
out of committee and are very likely to
pass I think most of those amendments
are not ill so for instance in writing
the law the law applies to employees and
the architects never intended to create
employee rights to data this was
supposed to be about consumers so it
fixes that the law also created what's
known as household identifiers and this
came about because of course a lot of
marketers say I don't I'm not personally
identifying you but I'm looking at your
household so isn't that a hack
well the problem then becomes this law
has access rights and you don't want
household members accessing so so
household identifiers coming out of out
of the law there's also a very important
amendment
surrounding Rhea dental vacation where
the law was extremely severe about what
is de-identified data and the new
approach is going to be less severe yet
you promise not to Rhea dental I which I
think publicly which i think is actually
a very nice outcome there's no need to
cement crazy terms around that not to
Rhea denta fight you publicly promise
the company has to publicly promise that
if you if you say I only use your
information at a de-identified way that
has the con commitment promise has to be
that you will not try to Rio Dental you
allow parties that you're in pretty with
to identify it and this goes to what's
happening in payments right now
retailers when you go to a retailer and
you swipe your credit card they're
creating a hash of your credit card and
then they're sending it to Experian and
they consider that D identified so
they'll say I don't sell your personal
information to anyone but what they're
doing is they're sending a unique hash
that Experian men says oh well that's
Chris and this is Chris's address and
then they send it back to the retailer
so so one of the hacks that happens and
privacy is I I don't sell data okay I
send out non personal identify but then
I buy it but then I buy identify abode
Atta and this is the many many tricks in
this trade here's one that's tractable
and in fact I think you know in looking
at Kobe and alone YZ paper I think you
are you were somewhat speaking to this
provision in the CCPA maybe maybe you
didn't know it or at the time but the
definition of personal data under the
CCPA includes probabilistic identifiers
and this was again you know kind of the
privacy advocacy
incentive to make privacy lost totally
bulletproof and Magisterial so personal
data is not just things like your SSN
and so on it's also any other identifier
that's more probably more probably not
based on categories of VIII so that's um
you know that introduces a mathematical
test pretty interesting this might get
removed and amendments third example in
the CCPA
but i think is important i mentioned
that the CCPA gives consumers a private
right of action so plaintiffs can go to
court and enforce it however you can
only enforce one provision of the CCPA
and that is the security breach
provision so if you if an individual is
a victim of a security breach and that
security breach is defined as
unauthorized access and exfiltration
so not just unauthorized access which
happens all the time as a result so
there's got to be a causal there's a
causal link here failure to implement
reasonable security procedures what are
those the consumer has to give notice to
the business and give that business 30
days to cure the breach I work a lot of
breaches no one cures these things okay
I mean so sometimes sometimes you'll
find the data you know some
sophisticated businesses will have
tethered laptops that do remote deletion
sometimes you'll think you had a breach
and you'll later learn you didn't really
have a breach and those are the times
you don't cure this community could talk
about what it means to cure in the sense
of risk does the data end up in the dark
web so on it's a type of thing
what I'm always told by my situation you
need to this is a state law a the injury
requirement you speak of is a federal
requirement that is not present in state
law so some state courts lead in a harm
requirement but this statute was written
so that a violation of the statutes
rights are an injury in themselves I
didn't put that in these many slides I
thought I thought this audience would
might not be as interested in that but
I'm wrong and so yeah this is this is a
statute that that where if your rights
are infringed you have you have injury
and you have a minimum recovery so you
can't sue for all these other things
like you know like if you look at like
let's say you violate this or if you
violate that or if you sell data
illegally can't sue only the Attorney
General can sue the business community
still hates this because curing a
security breach is probably impossible
in what they're going to have to argue
is that things like credit monitoring
are a cure but this is a group yummy you
laugh but okay
experts have to write articles out there
that say what the harm but what is the
continuing harm because the defense bar
will find some someone who completely
doesn't know what they're talking about
to say up and say actually you're better
off after a security breach you're
better off because now you have identity
monitoring there's an expert that
approach it's a smart approach it was
foreseen and blocked so the law has an
explicit provision that says that it
creates no other right of action because
otherwise you could tether this to let's
say California's Constitution which
provides an inalienable right to privacy
and so you could say I have a
constitutional tort against a company
here it's not just so this is um you
know this is a big deal for American
companies let's say you bring a suit
let's say there's a security breach
you're in the breach you bring a suit
the the cost the discovery costs and the
kind of getting ready cost is eight
hundred to eight hundred thousand to a
million dollars and so that's why they
want to stamp this out even if you win
you suffer a million dollar loss for
better or worse that's that's what's
happening out there so I thought these
are interesting aspects of the CCPA that
could be studied mathematically I
imagine it would be possible to study
let's say people who have identity theft
monitoring versus those who don't to see
if there's any difference in their rate
of victimization and so on those
questions are gonna end up getting
litigated in the time I have left let me
turn to some of the things in the GDP
are that are that are super interesting
and I think this is probably second
nature for many of the Europeans in the
room but I see the GDP are is important
in a lot of ways including that you know
in the u.s. you're allowed to use data
unless it's illegal so you're free we
live in a free society Europe processing
personal data is illegal unless you have
a basis and you know I'm going to talk
about some of these basis ease basis the
the one that the business community is
trying to use is legitimate interest so
I explain why in a minute
legitimate interest so this is the idea
that the company has a legitimate
interest to use personal data what's
super interesting about it is that it
sets up a balancing test for this
and way that you know takes in the full
range of risk and consideration of uses
of data so the legitimate interest is a
necessary use of data for a legitimate
interest pursued by the controller
itself which when those interests are
overridden by the interests of the data
subject so there's a balancing test and
the GDP are already settles one contest
you have a right to opt out of
controller marketing so first party
marketing you have an absolute right to
opt out so that that balance has been
answered so like what us what others
should we think about then why argue
that the non difference of the present
version is no it's not necessary
powerful I think there's gonna be
fantastic opportunities to articulate
what are best practices and like what
and to make demonstrations of what is
possible and if the regulator's can see
what is possible these provisions can
can really have real-life other part of
you to care and I don't know if you're
getting into that the subject access
rights where people can ask for what
they did about them and deletion or no
longer being processed and it turns out
there's kind of like sometimes depending
on the design and the engineering
there's a conflict between being able to
people's data subject access rights
especially if you apply the differential
privacy from the get-go and so that this
is one of the things that we're trying
to understand and it gets even more
complicated when you use mechanisms like
homomorphic encryption or multi quadrant
computation where you say I don't even
have the data and and so therefore I
don't even have a data protection
obligation and there's apparently like
what I've heard now through the
grapevine which I haven't seen that
there are two EU projects and one
concludes you are GDP are required to be
GPR compliant even if you use those
technologies and the other one come
close indeed like you can bypass gdpr if
you use from a new technology so I think
it's it's a it's a very interesting
interpretation what you just get it but
if you look at that if you look at GDP R
as a kind of vision that engineers just
have to develop it's a it requires two
kind of let's say solve conflicting
requirements and it's not so trivial
there is article 10 which says that if
you are asked to supply your personal
data so to meet that obligation the
controller has to be identified then
they don't have to so that means
basically that's why these two projects
okay looking at and more detail is
identity verification authentication
companies are up to some so for instance
when you go to like rent one of those
little scooters there they're performing
a mini background check on you and those
background checks are outside the Fair
Credit Reporting Act because its
identity verification rather than
reporting on reputation so it's outside
any regulatory regime in the US and some
of the techniques used are rather
dramatic and it's it's when I think
about those I think about this kind of
are my subjective interests more
important than their interest in losing
three dollars on our ride
because that's the you know the price
point is pretty low
another strategic goal so so legitimate
interests are important because in in
companies are using legitimate interests
as a basis for processing because the
gdpr makes it next to impossible whose
consent for processing and this was a a
an explicit goal of the GDP our GDP are
they basically elevated consent for
processing of personal data to something
that looks like you might recognize as
kind of a medical procedure level of of
consent so if you think about all the
consent we have in the world consent can
often be inferred by inaction and the
law recognizes that inaction can be a
form of consent but then if you go to
your physician your physician is
supposed to tell you about even
non-obvious or unlikely risks from a
procedure and the gdpr seems to capture
that you know it's free unambiguous
informed specific you're not allowed to
do this thing where you make I agree to
everything click here and so on and the
the reason why businesses can't use
consent is the right to withdraw my
experience has been that clients can't
architect a withdrawal right and as such
this just becomes a no-go for them so
maybe that changes maybe some wizard
develops systems where would that have
withdrawal rights and and so on so when
you look at the kaneo Canoe olds impose
this fine on google the fine is
important for its number but what's more
important is the ration rationale but
kaneo had four in fining google google
failed to essentially get informed
consent from data subjects before
tracking them and the knie land 'red is
high enough their interpretation of
consent is high enough that google
doesn't think that they can get consent
to track people so they're appealing
this one not about not because of the
fine because because fine means nothing
which you can only give valid consent
for a specified purpose and you're only
allowed to possess insofar as that
processing is necessary that means that
also means that if the purpose is
exhausted the fact that you cannot say
I'm not gonna cover biometrics but
biometrics had another layer of
stringency towards consent and as a
result all the platforms have turned off
face recognition in Europe it also
turned it off in Illinois because in
Illinois there is a a state biometric
Privacy Act with a private right of
action and Google has lost a couple
cases under it a couple decisions so
there is this notice that when you
travel to Europe now if you try to go to
google.com you can't you can't they
totally blocked it you're gonna be
rerouted to Google and L dot uk'
buh-buh-bah Google is really using their
geo their geo targeting to implement a
lot of this stuff so that they can do
things like turn off face recognition
and and the other other rights and you
know content Pilger
we have to go to too many different
websites to understand what this
tracking is and you can't even if you
read all that stuff you still don't
understand it I mean there is this weird
problem with consent and especially
informed consent
um the tracking is so complex that no
one can explain it therefore no one can
consent it helps
so what is the duration of your consent
is one way to think about this and maybe
your the duration of your consent was
long enough to to train a model
maybe it's abstracted at that point so
there's no meaning that your data is
still being processed after the models
trained CPR isn't is a pre machine
learning law this is a fundamental
problem with it it is it's dealing with
yesteryears privacy well then there's
still today's privacy conflicts it does
not do a good job with training a
statistical model explicitly said things
with only the language which are
protected and love to hear you speak in
more detail about the gdpr
Annabel well--that's during one of the
breaks so I mean a couple of other
strategic goals I mean one and this is
true also with the CCPA is to put is to
give advantages structural advantages to
first parties and and of course this is
greatly problematic for the ad tech
industry I think the gdpr is attempting
to strangle ad tech on some level
because it's actually a privacy
nightmare if you see how the data works
in those systems its just sent to many
many many different third parties very
quickly and so on GDP are you know it
could be the types of models that bring
back newspapers in first parties it
definitely favors human-in-the-loop data
analysis so you and I will disagree
about this bullet point so I you know
I've worked with Palantir for a long
time and I'm on their board and they're
cleaning up in Europe and the reason why
is because if you think about
intelligent systems what are the
affordances that intelligent systems
need both telogen systems need to ingest
many different forms of intelligence and
all the weird ways it comes to you and
you also have to deal with the problem
that um you're not certain about the
value of that information and its value
changes and gets recontextualized when
new data shows up so systems like
volunteer have deletion and recursive
deletion that allows you even if you
have let's say an intelligence report
that says we're concerned about X Y & Z
if new data come in that that undermine
the the underlying assumptions for those
determinations it can we basically
change the report and so it's one of the
few companies that can do gdpr which is
strange right and and I think probably a
lot of people are not so happy about
that I talked about that a bit more so
it I just have I have two minutes left I
see on
counter here so let me throw out two
other issues and maybe we could talk
about them more during the during the
discussion the gdpr has a concept of
high-risk data processing well we're
gonna have to develop a language of what
is risk right what do you what we even
consider risk what risks we consider are
even worth considering so like you know
here in the United States at any given
time about two to three percent of
Americans our victims of identity theft
so if you if you're in a security breach
in your the risk of you becoming a
victim of identity theft may be
negligible it might be like next to zero
against the background noise so we're
gonna have to start talking about
developing a risk what we think is risk
and what we think is high-risk and what
does that even mean I think those are
gonna be really exciting and then
there's there's this procedural issue
that I've helped clients with it's
hilarious if you determine that your
data collection implicates natural
rights and freedoms you have to do this
special report in which you talk about
you know you write a privacy impact
assessment and you talk about your need
for the data and the proportionality of
the processing and then you always
conclude that you have you've eliminated
the risk because if you could include
otherwise you have to go to the
regulator and tell them that you're
engaging in a high risk data processing
and you can't mitigate the risk awesome
huh so someday these these impact
assessments are going to become public
and we're gonna see crazy logic and
it'll be nice to have a rubric to talk
about that logic and then finally uh
security is super interesting in the GD
P R it has elements of risk based
regulation you have to think about the
sensitivity of your data the sensitivity
of the processing at the same time it
talks about state-of-the-art security
and you know the problem we're having in
the in the u.s. is that we can't agree
on what reasonable security is companies
are litigating
this issue and they're winning so
setting some type of evidence-based
standard of what is reasonable security
I mean what's the difference between
reasonable security and state of the art
something does it look like something
like that I don't know these are all
things that will be very interesting to
figure out and then finally security
breach notification is a little bit
different under the GD P are where
there's Supervisory Authority reporting
and if you go to the websites of the
like the UK ICO and you can see that
there is this fantastic curve of
reporting thousands and thousands and
thousands of breaches are being reported
now to the regulator's but then you
don't have to go on to report the data
subjects unless you have one of these
unless you have this these triggers so
again we're talking about risk-based
regulation how are we going to talk
about the rights and freedoms that are
relevant and what is considered high
risk especially when you know just from
what we know from security breaches is
that a lot of that data it just it goes
out there a very very small amount of it
is used for any type of offensive cyber
they typically do cream skimming you you
look through the database and you look
for people who have corporate cards and
stuff like that you steal their
identities and most of that data just
gets trashed so I could make the case
that even pretty dramatic security
breaches don't result in high risk some
risk but not high risk so I've taken all
my time and I'd love to hear Kobe's
response in any discussion
[Applause]
there should be another Mike did help me
well so Chris you might want to keep
your mic on - I'll take that one
so thanks for the paper I should thanks
for matching me with Chris this was
great and I think the paper that he sent
me and is the basis for the GDP GDP our
part of the talk is just an excellent
fit for all of us I'm gonna refer to it
many times in the next year's in the
next few years my experience is the
reading through a legal document like
that the GTR is very complicated for
mine and what I'm usually missing is
this overarching picture I can
understand maybe some of the articles
but then the paper gives all of this
extremely useful and I think we also
should walk like that just letting the
computer science ideas
I think the many ways of the GTRs a very
interesting document one of the things
that I understood from reading the paper
again is like the focus on enforcement
which is like an advancement with
respect to the previous the Protection
Directive and one person I was asking
myself is whether we can incorporate
some of these enforcement models into
about five to see like what I'm thinking
but like the wider sense was blocking
you know a private situation kind of
game - I think setting something like
that to understand better what is going
on I unpacked a notion of
identifiability is wider than it was
lost and I think this is very
interesting particularly night we're
looking at is extends identifiability in
the US will be very interesting to see
something like that would come back to
us I believe that this like that
viability singing out other technical
terms such as data deletion data
minimization and so on they do they're
not formally defined but they do need
this methodical treatment and I think
getting better understanding from the
law side of what is meant by responsible
to help us hopefully do this
formalization and maybe then we can go
back to you and say all these
expectations are unrealistic maybe they
should be reinterpreted or modified so
this I think is also very interesting
and so connected to that if maybe this
like the final portal mentioned I think
that the gdpr lacks lags with respect to
the current understanding of privacy in
machine learning and this is a question
how do we deal with legislation that was
written without these understandings or
with limited understanding of some of
these issues but we still need to go
with it and apply this is even stronger
with the US legislation there gdpr
is right if we advance to the especially
privacy and I think that's gonna be
interesting questions for us as a
community how how we go with um the
remote disagrees what I think what we
both said about machine learning and
maybe
well actually the room is mics so
er that it's going to and you look at
the case law of the European courts the
advisory board then I think you must
conclude from that that there are a
number of business models that are based
a very specific type of machine learning
namely using behavioral data that in my
opinion suffer from all the biases that
are that have been out there for machine
learning so this is models that are
based on that machine learning
low-hanging fruit data that because this
piece of legislation was designed very
cleverly these metal business models
will not run now whenever I say that
people look at me and say oh mirror you
are so naive and then I say ok if you
want to run with your head into the wall
with your fantastic business models so
people always say China and United
States will do it all and Europe will be
left behind
because the gdpr doesn't understand
machine learning I think the GDP our
will limit bad fever yes equilibrium and
that's very good news it's not a sign
that they did not understand it but they
said this is not what we want and I know
some of the people who actually wrote
the GDP are they are extremely aware of
that and they have agenda of course the
GTRs compromises we all know how it
works the data protection impact
assessment for instance that you
and the requirement the condition that
must be fulfilled if you have that
obligation to have that obligation
there is recital 75 which gives a whole
lot of reasons there is the EDB opinion
which gives our criterion so quite
aspect with a lot of examples there are
I think now around 22 listings by the
national debates that say this list of
processing types Pietro advertising all
fall by definition under that obligation
so I think the gdpr is like an
architecture so it's been very well
thought out there are a lot of cross
linkages and the actual implementation
and interpretation is left to the courts
in first instance to those who are doing
the data processing but because of the
implementation chapter indeed are there
going to be I think all the first day
that it went into application so 23rd
eighty-six cases were already brought to
the courts so I actually don't
understand this recurring claim just
because certain business powers are
going to be rolled out that doesn't mean
they didn't understand it no it's a very
good thing can I give an example in the
context of privacy there are exceptions
in the GDR for suspending for research
and statistical purposes these
exceptions are ignoring the fact fact
that we know now leakages accumulate
from these releases in nature and once
you do that this is an example of point
work the standard legal standard lags
behind our current whether you think
that privacy is the same as hiding
personal day so to me I think that's the
position of the GDP our privacy means
that you are to some extent have a
certain measure of influencing what data
can be persist about so if you narrowly
define privacy as leaking of data but
that's not privacy particularly have you
you know that they in internally they
check so I'm just very curious about
this because I think I would often have
a snide remark that says let's say deep
mind and Google you know deep mind was a
very attractive target and maybe as
maybe Google decided then
they wanted the information but as a
third party they couldn't now what they
did is they go buy it then once that
Odent it being different if they deep
mind or it being whatever company issue
has like valuable data that you want
desert is that the definition of first
party third party so then when you go to
any kind of Google Earth property then
in relation to that property everything
else that Google alphabet or whatever
their own becomes first party
because of ownership this is a very good
question in its actually lie in the CCPA
right now so Google wants an amendment
to the CCPA to eliminate so with the
CCPA does it gives you a right to opt
out of third-party data sail to the top
down but of course what you know Larry
Page you know that people realize that
the people who opt out are special and
you can't let people opt out because
it's the people who opt out and we're
actually the most valuable they're the
affluent people are the ones who opt out
and so on so Google wants to change the
CCPA that currently it says you can't
sell data to another business or a third
party they want to remove another
business quite well they obviously see a
hole in the definition of third party
and in it might concentrate so here's
one of a perverse problem of privacy law
it's going to trigger concert
concentration and companies are going to
buy other companies for the data that's
going to be one of it and so then we
have to start thinking about other types
of interventions the court explicitly
said that Google Silicon Valley was not
really involved
because it was the daughter of the GPR
that was the actual controller Google
wants fire that don't turn reliable I
think the issue here is more than
article 30 and 40 mega distinction
between the information that you have to
provide if the data was provided to you
as a controller directly it has nothing
to do with when you do a part of some
company or not that's article 13 article
14 is if you change the date from
something else not directly from the
subject so if Google brain is part of
article 14 advice if I did not provide
my data to the issue here would be more
in the legal ground so if I don't know
anything about a new brain then I cannot
have consented to sharing my data are
the divisions within the company even
sort of well-defined I'm not interested
if I have never heard of Google brain I
have not shared the identity of the data
controller has to be provided but if
that's just like alphabet that's not
right and I mean I'm not being it snide
I just like I don't understand what it
means - it's not clear to me - which the
divisions within a company like like
alphabet or are meaningful I mean
obviously there are divisions right
to some part not additional structures
like sir company let's let companies
decide where their boundaries are and
then we penalize them based on the
revenue of whatever that battery yes
Nick your boundaries
sure you date her we pick that but we're
gonna penalize you got the whole thing
into that allow it before the free
routine life so you see data sharing is
of mine but I think just how did you
bring a car and if it's one of the smart
things with the GDP are you can be big
but we responsible can you say that
alpha that might actually be like a
separate legal entity right that was a
bad example bit like like to what extent
you know you ideally you want to set
things up so people don't just play
games of like labeling what that company
is yeah so that's why the Google Spain
case
so that's right case well surprise
because AHA we see an advertising entity
that is actually targeting advertising
in Spain so whatever you call it you are
addressing European citizens
did you PR that is more I think the
third party issue comes up in the fact
that when you give your consent
the identity well I thought it'd be
interesting to go back a bit more than
this machine learning questions that
didn't get resolved you know for one
thing it's not fair to expect
legislators to solve problems that we
don't as computer scientists understand
and there's a lot of be nice food
something that could came up come out of
this is some concrete questions around
you know when has a machine learning
model successfully deleted and forgotten
of an individual I'm not sure if that's
a good example or what the you know what
what machine learning questions these
laws sort of raised that we could try
something I think it's in principle
possible to direct language that is
cognizant of the possibility of
something like machine learning model or
published statistics or whatever
encoding within it personal data are
there so that when you draft some
language you're aware of this
possibility in it and you have to like
the interpretation of where the model is
identifying or anonymous could adapt
with community art techniques or
understanding because the problem is not
that's impossible I think the problem is
that that's not what we have we don't
have AI as far as I read it we don't
have but very adaptive notions with
things like Mira's reaction was that we
don't want that and I'd be curious to
hear like we don't want we don't want
language that that's cognizant of the
fact that like say a nearest neighbor
model can encode like
asia-pacific like I'm curious what sort
of silly there are different things like
we discussed recycle 26 which gives some
guidelines on under the GDP are if
singling out is possible
high reasonably likely it's personal
data so the the GP are going to say so
and it's not so it says if it is highly
likely a number of examples in one of
those examples is I know there is so